DANA PERINO, JUAN WILLIAMS,
JESSE WATTERS, AND
KATIE PAVLICH.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> THIS WAS YESTERDAY?
IT WAS OUT THE DOOR.
AND SHATTERED BOTH OPTIONS.
BOTH SUFFERED FATAL WOUNDS.
BOTH OFFICERS DID NOT DRAW THEIR
WEAPONS, DID NOT FIRE.
NEVER STOOD A CHANCE.
>> Greg: SATURDAY TWO POLICE
OFFICERS WERE AMBUSHED AND
KILLED IN TEXAS, THEIR NAMES AND
45, 39.
THEY BECAME VICTIMS.
IF THAT IS THE STORY OF MANY
OFFICERS LIVES.
WE REPORT IT ON THE SHOW,
BECAUSE WE REALIZE THE
PROPORTION OF MEDIA COVERAGE ON
SUCH CRIMES COMPARED TO OTHER
STORIES IS OBVIOUSLY LACKING.
WHEN A VIOLENT ACT OCCURS THAT
FITS A NARRATIVE, IT IS
AMPLIFIED TO SUIT THE MEDIA’S
NEED.
WHAT NEED DOES IT SERVE TO
REPORT A STORY OF TWO DEAD
OFFICERS?
FOR THE REST OF THE MEDIA, VERY
LITTLE.
SO THEY SHRUG IT OFF, BUT
FOX NEWS WON’T.
TODAY WE ARE LIVING IN AN
EXPERIMENT, ONE CONDUCTED BY MAD
SOCIAL SCIENTIST WHERE I MEDIA
AND PLATFORMS TO STORIES THAT
MANIPULATE A MOTION FOR THE SAKE
OF CLICKS.
THEY PUT A PRICE ON REGION SO IT
BY THE MINUTE.
SO THAT THE BRAVERY AND
HARDSHIPS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
IGNORED IN FAVOR OF VISUAL
CONTENT, TIED TO A NARRATIVE.
IN 2020 IRONICALLY THE MEDIA
REFUSES TO CLEARLY SEE THE TRUTH
OF POLICING.
INSTEAD BUSHING STORIES THAT
ALARM AND DIVIDE CITIZENS.
THIS RIFT IS NOW ENERGIZING
VIOLENT CRIMINALS AS DEMOCRAT
MAYORS AND OTHER POLITICIANS
FOLLOW THE SAME PATH DESERTING
LAW AND ORDER AND THEREFORE YOU.
AND THEY LAUGH AT THOSE WHO TRY
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
POLITICIANS ARE SCARED OF THE
MOB.
SCARED OF THE MEDIA AS BOTH
SHEER MAYHEM OVER POLICE
OFFICERS.
AND IF YOU CHEER THE POLICE, YOU
ARE MADE AND UNPERSON BY THE
MOB.
GO AHEAD, SAY BLUE LIVES MATTERS
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE NOT READ ORWELL
ORWELL, YOU CAN LIVE IT.
UNTIL WE DECIDED ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH, MAKING YOU ANGRY OR SAD,
YOU CAN DECIDE WHEN ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
SO KATIE, SAVANNAH CHAVEZ IS THE
DAUGHTER OF ONE OF THE SLAIN
OFFICERS, AND SHE WENT ON
TWITTER AND TWEETED HER SORROW
WITH A HASHTAG OF
#BlueLivesMatter WHICH DREW
ATTACK AND MOCKERY, INCLUDING A
CHECKER WHO CALLED THE HASHTAG
RACISTS.
IF SO SHE DELETED IT AFTER
WARNING HER OWN DAD.
ALL OF THIS SEEMS LIKE AN
INEVITABILITY IN A CLIMATE WHERE
WE PAINT PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
PROTECT OUR SAFETY AS THE
PROBLEM.
>> Katie: I THINK THAT’S WHY
THE SITUATION IS SO FRUSTRATING,
BECAUSE LOGIC AND FACTS, AND
MORNING OF POLICE OFFICERS WHO
HAVE MADE THE SACRIFICE TO TRY
TO BREAK OUT A DOMESTIC DISPUTE
IS SOMEHOW RACIST EVEN THOUGH
THE POLICE AND THE SITUATION
WERE MINORITIES.
THIS IS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION, THE CURRENT
RHETORIC, AND PEOPLE GIVING INTO
THIS IDEA, POLITICIANS
SPECIFICALLY THAT IT IS OKAY TO
ENGAGE IN POLICY DECISIONS BASED
ON THIS MOB MENTALITY OF A
DEMAND THAT THEY ARE GIVEN.
POLICE, WE CAN SAY ALL DAY LONG
GO OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY TO FIGHT
THEMSELVES.
AND WE SEE IT.
IN THE COUNTRY WILL COME TO A
POINT WHERE I’M ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
IT IS A SCARY SITUATION, BECAUSE
WE LOOK AT THE ST. LOUIS COUPLE
WHO DARED TO DEFEND THEIR
PRIVATE PROPERTY WITH FIREARMS
WHEN THERE WAS A MOB ON THE
FRONT LAWN ARE BEING PROSECUTED
BY THE FAR LEFT PROSECUTOR IN
THAT TOWN, IN THAT CITY.
SO THAT’S A PROBLEM.
BUT AT SOME POINT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO VOTE OUT AND
MAKE A DECISION BASED ON THIS
MOB MENTALITY AND STAND UP FOR
WHAT IS RIGHT AND THE RULE OF
LAW, BECAUSE THERE IS NO OTHER
WAY TO REALLY DO IT.
>> Greg: DANA, SO FAR
YEAR-OVER-YEAR, WE SAW 600%
INCREASE IN SHOOTINGS.
600%, AND A 483 PERCENT IN
SHOOTING VICTIMS.
BUT AOC HAS A THEORY ON WHY THIS
IS THE CASE.
AND I WANT TO PLAY THIS AND GET
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> DO WE THINK THAT THIS HAS TO
DO WITH THE FACT THAT THERE IS
RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW?
MAYBE IT HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT PAYING THEIR
RENT AND ARE SCARED TO PAY THE
RENT.
SO THEY GO OUT AND THEY NEED TO
FEED THEIR CHILD, AND THEY DON’T
HAVE MONEY, AND SO YOU MAYBE
HAVE TOO -- THEY ARE PUT IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY EITHER NEED TO SHOPLIFT
SOME BREAD OR GO HUNGRY THAT
NIGHT.
>> Greg: SO DANA, WHEN YOU
HEAR THIS, YOU MUST THINK HOW
IRONIC AND BIZARRE IT IS SAID
THAT SHE IS BLAMING VIOLENCE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT GIVEN HER ROLE IN
CREATING ACTUAL UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> Dana: YES, WE ARE THINKING
ALIKE, EVEN IN A PANDEMIC.
A SOMETHING MIGHT HELP
UNEMPLOYMENT MIGHT BE AN AMAZON
CENTER THAT WAS ACTUALLY
PANDEMIC PROOF, AMAZON IS DOING
GREAT IN THE PANDEMIC.
AND TO THE VIOLENCE THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IS NOT A MOTHER
HUDDLING WITH A LOAF OF BREAD
UNDER HER COAT LIKE JEAN VALJUAN
IN LES MISSOURI BOWLS.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE MEDIA
COVERAGE, THE PAINTING OF THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MURAL, WHICH
I DON’T KNOW WHY WE CALL IT A
MURAL, THAT GOT SO MUCH MEDIA
ATTENTION, AND HAVE YOU SEEN
BILL de BLASIO ANYWHERE?
TALKING ABOUT ANY OF THIS?
THE OTHER THING THAT I WANTED TO
POINT OUT, AND THE REASON WHY I
WAS REALLY INTERESTED IN THE
CASE IN TEXAS, THE THING THAT WE
HEARD ABOUT A LOT ABOUT IS THAT
SOME COMMUNITIES THINK IT WOULD
BE BETTER TO SEND A SOCIAL
WORKER TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SCENES, BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
CALLING THE WAY A FATHER, ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT YOU HAVE TO
SEND AN OFFICER IS BECAUSE IT IS
OFTEN A PLACE OF VIOLENCE.
AND YOU ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
THE WOMEN AND THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE IN HARM’S WAY.
SO I THINK THAT THE SOCIAL
WORKER THING IS NOT GOING TO
WORK ON ITS OWN.
>> Greg: TO DANA’S POINT WITH
THE BLACK LIVES MURAL OR
PAINTING, WE HAVE A MEDIA THAT
IS SO FOCUSED ON SYMBOLISM AS
OPPOSED TO THE ACTUAL REALITY
WHICH IS WHAT OCCURRED SATURDAY.
TWO MEN WERE LOST AND THAT MURAL
WOULD NOT SAVE THEM.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT THEY
MURAL REPRESENTS WHAT THE NATION
SAW AND A VIDEO WHERE A POLICE
OFFICER WAS KNEELING ON A MAN’S
NECK FOR NEARLY 9 MINUTES IN THE
MAN DIED, GREG.
SO I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
REACTING TO THAT.
AND I THINK IN GENERAL POLICE
HAVE A DANGEROUS JOB, MY
CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO THOSE
OFFICERS WHO DIED, THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT IT’S MORE STRESSFUL WHEN
THEY HAVE THIS CURTAIN TL POLICE
OFFICERS ABUSING THE PUBLIC
TRUST IN PUBLIC AUTHORITY AND
PEOPLE ARE DYING AND PEOPLE
QUESTION LOGICALLY EXACTLY WHAT
THE POLICE ARE DOING.
SO AT THE MOMENT, I THINK WHAT
WE ARE SAYING IS EVEN IN A MORE
STRESSFUL SITUATION ADDED TO THE
GEORGE FLOYD PRESSURE, BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE SPIKE IN CRIME, BUT
LET ME SAY THAT THE SPIKE IN
CRIME IS ALMOST SOLELY IN BLACK
AND BROWN NEIGHBORHOODS, AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN NEW YORK,
CHICAGO, I COULD GO ON.
AND WHAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
HERE IS THE PROBLEM OF GANGS,
DRUG DEALERS, DOMESTIC ABUSE IN
SOME CASES THAT LEADS TO THE
SPIKE IN VIOLENCE IN THE EASY
ASPECT TO GUNS.
IF WE REALLY CARE ABOUT THIS
LOSS OF LIFE, I THINK WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES,
WHICH ARE ON DISPLAY, EVERYTHING
FROM THE BAD SCHOOLS TO THE
INABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET GOOD
FOOD, TO THE POOR QUALITY IN
GENERAL OF LIFE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT A KID DOES NOT
EVEN HAVE A CHANCE TO SUCCEED OR
DOES NOT FEEL LIKE THAT ANYWAY.
THE CULTURE IS TERRIBLE, IN
TERMS OF THE MUSIC, THAT’S MY
THING.
BLACK LIVES MATTER SHOULD BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THAT MOVEMENT
AS WELL.
THEY SHOULD BE SAYING DON’T
ALLOW BLACK LIVES MATTER TO
SIMPLY BE ABOUT THE POLICE.
IT SHOULD BE ABOUT HOW BLACK
PEOPLE TREAT EACH OTHER.
SO I THINK ON ALL OF THOSE
LEVELS WE HAVE TO BE HONEST.
THIS IS NOT A CITYWIDE CRIME
SPREE ANYWHERE, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS HAPPENING IN
OUR MOST DESPERATE COMMUNITIES.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE,
JUAN MENTIONS A LOT OF
VARIABLES, BUT THEY EXISTED
BEFORE THIS MASSIVE SPIKE, SO
CLEARLY SOMETHING ELSE IS ADDED
ON TO THIS THAT HAS LITTLE TO DO
WITH THOSE OTHER VARIABLES.
>> Jesse: WE KNOW WHAT THAT
IS.
AND I WANT TO SALUTE JUAN FOR
SAYING WHAT HE SAID.
I AGREE WITH ALMOST EVERYTHING
JUAN JUST SAID.
AND I WOULD ADD THAT A LOT OF
THESE PROBLEMS IN THE CITIES
WHERE YOU ARE SEEING THE
CARNAGE, THEY HAVE BEEN RUN BY
DEMOCRATS FOR 50 YEARS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN SEEING THE SAME
THING AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
SO MAYBE IF WE CHANGE THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS, WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THE PERSON OR PEOPLE THAT
ARE RUNNING THAT SYSTEM.
IN TERMS OF THE MEDIA, THEY
DON’T REPORT THE NEWS, THEY JUST
REPORT A NARRATIVE, THAT’S WHY
HALF OF THE COUNTRY IS ANGRY OR
UNENLIGHTENED, THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THE TRUTH.
THAT’S WHY PEOPLE COME TO FOX TO
HEAR THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH IS THERE IS A CRIME
WAVE GOING ON.
NEW YORK CITY HOMICIDES ARE UP
20%.
KANSAS CITY HAS HAD ITS MOST
DEADLY YEAR EVER.
CHICAGO, DEADLIEST YEAR SO FAR
IN 25 YEARS.
AND I CAN KEEP NAMING CITIES.
WE HAD A WHITE MOM KILLED AFTER
SHE SAID ALL LIVES MATTER IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
THERE WAS A HISPANIC MAN THAT
DROVE HIS TRUCK AND MURDERED A
WHITE GUY BECAUSE HE SAYS HE
HATES WHITE PEOPLE AND HATES
DONALD TRUMP.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH A HATE CRIME
HATE CRIME.
THERE IS STUFF LIKE THIS ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
I CAME BACK TO THE CITY THE
OTHER WEEK DOWN IN LOWER
MANHATTAN, THERE IS A WHOLE
BLACK LIVES MATTER IN CANTON BY
CITY HALL, YOU CANNOT JOG NEAR
THERE, YOU CAN’T WALK YOUR DOG.
YOU CAN’T RUN A STROLLER, IT
SMELLS WORSE THAN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THEY DESECRATED
ARCHITECTURAL MASTERPIECES, SOME
OF THE ARCHITECTURE, SOME OF THE
BUILDINGS IN THAT AREA, JUST
VANDALIZED WITH GRAFFITI THAT
SAYS F THE PIGS OR F THE COPS.
IT’S HORRIBLE.
SO THE DEMOCRATS THINK THEY CAN
RIDE THE WAVE OF ENERGY IN
NOVEMBER AND WIN.
I THINK THAT IT’S WRONG.
IT IS A CRIME WHY IF THAT IS
GOING TO BLOW UP IN THE FACE.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
AND IT WILL DESTROY THEIR CITIES